this episode of real engineering is
brought to you by breed a problem
solving website that teaches you to
think like an engineer this subject
needs no introduction the entire world
is talking about the same thing
kovat 19 has turned the world upside
down in just a couple of weeks and the
human race is scrambling to adapt to
this new pandemic kovat 19 is racing
through populations for many the
symptoms are mild for others the virus
debilitates them their lungs ability to
transfer carbon dioxide and oxygen in
and out of their blood begins to fall
each breath becomes more labored until
eventually they become too exhausted to
breathe on their own the patients that
are presenting to hospitals with these
symptoms need medical intervention
before they suffocate unfortunately we
do not have a cure the best medical
treatment currently is to simply assist
their lung function with mechanical
ventilation but hospitals are
experiencing such huge influxes of
patients that they do not have enough
ventilators to cope this has led to a
call out to Annie and all capable of
manufacturing ventilators to join the
fight against this common enemy
Medtronic a company I have worked for in
the past has its primary ventilator
manufacturing facility based in my
hometown of Galway here they produce
this ventilator the puritan Bennett 980
mechanical ventilator a top-of-the-line
high performance ventilator that would
give doctors a huge leg up in combating
the viral pneumonia that patients are
experiencing but it's a complicated bit
of machinery they currently produce 225
units a week and are pulling employees
from the stent manufacturing facility I
worked at to help boost production to
500 a week this however won't come even
close to fulfilling the demand that is
yet to peak there is an impending doom
looming over us that soon hospitals and
countries like the US will experience
what Italy has already experienced an
overwhelming flood of patients so many
enthusiastic engineers who want to help
out are volunteering their expert
to develop a low-cost ventilator that
any manufacturing facility can adapt to
built every single design I've come
across centers around one key bit of
technology a BVM or bag-valve-mask B VMs
are plastic bags that a clinical care
practitioner can manually deflate with
their hands it's what a first responder
would use if a patient wasn't breathing
instead of giving mouth-to-mouth
resuscitation
it's a cheap and easy way to force air
into the lungs all these designs are
basically just robotic arms that can
squeeze the bag at a set frequency
endlessly they of course could be
manufactured quickly and in great
numbers but ventilators aren't just air
pumps that force air into a patient's
lungs one of the primary problems facing
doctors currently is managing a side
effect of mechanical ventilation borrow
trauma to understand this we first need
to understand how the lungs operate
under normal conditions so let's have a
quick biomechanics class on breathing
with our sister channel real science two
muscle groups typically act to control
breathing the diaphragm which is a large
muscle which separates the abdomen from
the chest and they intercostal muscles
which are the muscles which reside
between the bones of your ribcage when
you breathe in your diaphragm contracts
which causes it to move toward the
abdominal cavity while the external
intercostal muscles between the ribs
also contract which lifts the ribcage
outwards both of these actions increase
the volume of the thoracic cavity the
cavity that your lungs reside in the
increase in volume causes a
corresponding decrease in pressure which
allows air outside the body at
atmospheric pressure to fill the lungs
and equalize the pressure the key thing
to note here is that negative pressure
drives inhalation the lungs don't
inflate like a balloon they
and and equalize with atmospheric
pressure on exhalation the process
reverses with a small spike above
atmospheric pressure to push the air out
again mechanical ventilation cannot work
like this it has to force air into the
lungs from outside the body and
essentially blow the lungs up like a
balloon if this is not tightly
controlled the air pressure could work
against the diaphragm and the
intercostal muscles and end up
increasing the pressure in the alveoli
above their typical max pressure the
alveoli are tiny thin air sacs in the
lung that are in contact with blood
vessels to allow oxygen and carbon
dioxide to diffuse between the blood and
the lungs to do this they have to be
extremely thin because of that they are
very delicate pieces of tissue over
expanding them will lead to inflammation
at best or rupture at worst this is what
Barrow trauma is to make this worse
those suffering from acute respiratory
distress syndrome like those affected by
kovat 19 are more at risk of suffering
from this side effect of mechanical
ventilation as the alveoli that are
filled with fluid prevent air from
entering them causing the pressure to
elevate even higher in the functioning
alveoli the last thing we want to do is
damage the healthy tissue of a patient
suffering from damaged lung tissue that
is the opposite of helping to avoid this
doctors need to carefully choose their
settings on the ventilator the primary
guidance for this is to limit the volume
and pressure of air entering the lungs
so any low-cost ventilator will need a
method to control these settings designs
like this one which can only vary its
volume output as far as I can tell by
connecting the push rod closer to the
center of rotation of the cam there is
no variable control here this device
would likely do more harm than good
the designers heart is of course in the
right place but if a youtuber can spend
a day reading a ventilator design book
so can they however my patience goes to
zero for massive multi-million dollar
companies like Virgin Orbitz who present
these designs as their own who
clearly have done zero research into
what is needed from a ventilator and
just build something as quickly as
possible to get some positive PR for
their company look they even had time to
put up a big sign behind them for the
video as far as I can tell the earliest
design that proposed using these B VMs
was from an MIT student project from
2010 this paper has been online that
entire time and if people are truly
copying us they're leaving out some
clever design ideas that make it more
functional their design include a
spirometer which measures the air flow
rate out of the B VM by integrating this
value over time they can calculate the
volume of air delivered this then feeds
into a controller which can vary how
tightly the B VM was squeezed to change
the volume of air delivered this gives
the device a nice range of tidal volumes
ranging from 200 milliliters to 750 this
is the better design and may be useful
in a do-or-die situation but it is not
perfect the breaths per minute
controller is simply set on a time-based
frequency ranging from 5 to 30 breaths
per minute this is called a mandatory
breath it's entirely determined by the
Machine you will take a breath whether
you like it or not this would obviously
be uncomfortable and requires the
patient to be heavily sedated to the
point of paralysis but it can also
exacerbate barotrauma
if the patient's diaphragm and
intercostal muscles are resisting the
inhalation high performance ventilators
can work like this but they typically
don't their breath sequences are
normally triggered by the patient they
are still able to breathe they just need
help because they are exhausting
themselves with the effort in order to
do this the machine needs some way of
triggering the breath cycle and ending
it too based on observations of the
patient this can be done in a number of
ways it can be pressure triggered where
a sensor detects a drop in airway
pressure indicating that thoracic cavity
is expanding it can be flow triggered
where a sensor detects air flow into the
lungs or it can be triggered by a sensor
detecting electrical activity of the
diaphragm indicating that the diaphragm
is contracting to expand the thoracic
cavity this also requires very fast
micro processors to detect and react to
the triggers I have seen no low-cost
ventilators incorporating this vital
component of ventilator design and it is
a truly vital component a very difficult
part of the ventilation process is
winning people off it again a ventilator
which requires someone to be sedated to
the point of paralysis makes it very
difficult to get them breathing
naturally on their own again there are a
multitude of other design considerations
to be made with ventilators I studied
biomedical engineering and there is a
heavy emphasis on medical subjects like
surgical practice many of which are
taught by doctors not engineers
the first thing those doctors taught us
is to start your design by speaking to
the end-user the doctor
I spoke with Roland Francis a doctor who
runs the fantastic med life crisis
channel to get a better understanding of
some of the other things we engineers
need to remember when designing these
machines thanks Brian as you've already
heard Kovan 19 patients frequently
develop an acute respiratory distress
like syndrome or a RDS which not only
fills the alveoli with fluid making gas
exchange harder but also increases the
likelihood of the alveoli collapsing
shut at the end of every breath out this
is because disease areas of lung don't
produce surfactant normally polymer a
surfactant is a clever substance
produced by alveolar cells which coats
their inner surface and one of its key
jobs is keeping these tiny sacs open
when the lungs are deflated which is
what happens in healthy lungs but in a
RDS when you breathe out those alveoli
collapse shut and sometimes whole
sections of the lung collapse called
eight electus trying to force them open
with every breath requires more pressure
and hugely increases the risk of
barotrauma
so we use something called positive and
end expiratory pressure or peep to try
to prevent this I usually explain this
by saying imagine you've got your head
stuck out of the window of a fast-moving
car with your mouth open
don't do this by the way in addition to
all the insects you'll get in your mouth
you also have a constant air pressure
exerted on your airway making it ever so
slightly harder to breathe out and that
peep-peep is a constant positive
pressure that prevents those alveoli
collapsing at the end of each breath and
also helps open up or recruit collapse
areas of lung in kovat 19 we are seeing
patients requiring very high levels and
type control of peep to maintain their
oxygen levels and protect the lungs and
this is something that a basic bag
squeezing vent cannot really achieve
from the mechanisms I've seen so far I'd
be very concerned about the possibility
of Barrow and or volume trummer most of
these patients are on a ventilator for a
few weeks at the moment and a basic bag
squeezer might be able might be adequate
for the first day or so when a patient
is deeply sedated but simply won't work
as you try to ease off the sedatives
additionally your upper airway is warm
and humidify air entering the lungs but
they're taken out of the equation by the
endotracheal tube which goes directly
into the lower Airways without the
warming and humidifying features of
modern ventilators lung tissue will get
rapidly damaged this isn't even a
ventilator it's an anesthetic machine
because the ventilators I was going to
film with are in use right now and even
this big thing can only provide very
basic ventilation and while we do need
more ventilators what's even more
valuable are the intensive care nurses
and respiratory therapists needed to
work them but they take significantly
longer to produce so as you can probably
tell there is a lot more to ventilation
than just pumping air into a patient
theis regulation of pressure volume
oxygen percentage control and
humidification would all require more
complicated mechanics than these simple
BVM pumps designing a ventilator fit for
purpose with cheap and easy to
manufacture components is a difficult
job but I'm positive a viable product
will come to light soon especially as
this is not a new problem poorer
countries have been struggling with the
lack of cheaper medical supplies for
years and there are products like this
one from an Indian robotics engineer
which uses an android phone as the user
interface
it was on the market long before this
pandemic started and was designed to
help poorer families treat their loved
ones at home so the need for trained
medical personnel to run it is lower to
I can find very little information on
its capabilities but the company has
received massive orders from the Indian
government already
unfortunately India has banned all
exports of medical devices like this but
its manufacturer is licensing the design
we are all in this together and I hope
this video doesn't come across as a
teardown of well-intentioned engineers
trying to help it's much easier to point
out the flaws in a design than to
actually put in the time to design
something yourself this is just an
attempt to point people in the right
direction inspiring future generations
of Engineers is the mission of this
channel which is why I partnered with
today's sponsor brilliant many people
are on the lookout for online math and
science resources right now and whether
you're a student looking to get ahead a
professional brushing up on cutting-edge
topics or someone who just wants to take
some time to understand the world better
you should check out brilliant you've
already seen that there is a lot of
physics and engineering that go into
designing medical devices like
ventilators and brilliant has excellent
courses that unravels the interesting
physics in the world around you called
physics of the everyday insight you'll
learn things like how the behavior of an
expanding ideal gas is used to build a
refrigerator and how the energy
requirements of the muscles in your body
scales with the body size from mice to
elephants you can set a goal to improve
yourself and then work at that goal a
little bit every day brilliant makes
that easy with interactive explorations
and a mobile app that you can take with
you wherever you are if you are
naturally curious want to build your
problem-solving skills or need to
develop confidence in your analytical
abilities then get brilliant premium to
learn something new every day
brilliant thought-provoking math science
and computer science content helps guide
you to mastery by taking complex
concepts and breaking them up into
bite-sized understandable chunks
you'll start by having fun with their
interactive explorations and over time
you'll be amazed at what you can
accomplish as always thanks for watching
and thank you to all my patreon
supporters if you would like to see more
from me the links to my Instagram
Twitter subreddit and discord server are
below